When Elan was on the podcast,
he was talking to me about his neuro link
thing that he's going to be coming out
with. He said back then, and this
was what was that, three months ago?
Yeah.
Somewhere around three months ago.
He said that they were going to be coming
out with it within four to six months.
So that's any day now.
So I don't know what the fuck this is,
but he said essentially it's going to,
it's going to open up the bandwidth
between you and information.
It's going to radically change the
way human beings information. Uh, it,
the way human beings access
information and it's like a,
an internet thing wouldn't tell me.
Oh mark,
that's all he would tell the link nor
a link. Yeah. Cause it's on, you know,
we were on air when he was saying it.
I oddly trust him to be a phenomenal,
uh,
a net positive for the universe. Oh
hundred percent. You know, it was like a,
like Zuckerberg and like other times
like a net doesn't net negative for us.
Like they are the reasons.
They are a lot of the reason why society
has gone the way it has like cause you
can confirm whatever the fuck.
But Ilan, I'm like, yeah man,
why not fucking build a car that
you don't need any gasoline for?
Why not fucking send shit to this space?
I think he's a net positive for us.
I'm 100% convinced he's a net positive.
I think he's a legitimate genius and
I don't think just on a broad of them,
I think Mark Zuckerberg is a smart guy,
was very ambitious.
I think there's a big difference.
It wasn't Zuckerberg quote that I read
recently that what's good for the world
is not necessarily good for Facebook.
I'm like, that's it. Shut it down.
They said that burn it to the ground.
That's whole out.
Pull out, pull out. He's I,
what the fuck did you just say?
How much money do you have? Jesus, first
of all, don't you have like $18 billion?
How much more do you need bitch?
You sitting over here talking about what's
good for Facebook is not necessarily
good for the world.
Got All the good,
you got all the good for 18 fucking
hundred lifetimes. Jesus Christ.
He said that, that's exactly
that. My favorite Zuckerberg joke,
uh, we, I was at, we were at update
and this was when Zuckerberg is, uh,
uh,
being grilled by Congress and when he's
sipping water like this and Chris rock
comes by and he goes, uh, you know,
I didn't like about that trial.
There's nothing worse than watching
someone or being grilled by Congress when
there's no stakes.
Nothing happens to mark Zuckerberg if
even if the shit goes worse for him,
you know, like the nothing happens
to that guy. Right. That's my face.
Like I'm just like,
you never think about it that way
where nothing happens to him. If,
if even if Facebook blows up,
well,
here's what could happen if
Facebook intentionally colluded,
if there was some sort of proof that
they received some financial compensation
to lean one way or the other.
Is that,
is that was it's percolating
right now? No, but it could be,
this is what they were searching for when
searching for is what we're trying to
find out.
How is it that these Russian bots are
able to disseminate propaganda so readily
and so easily and so efficiently?
What are you doing? Stop that.
How has all this stuff propagated?
Like where's this coming from?
And the people that were asking were
techno ignorant and that was a part of the
problem.
So it was like a Google makes the iPhone,
right?
He's going to fucking ask him to
Google it. So how come my niece,
who's got bad words on her iPhone and
that someone has to tell them Google
doesn't make the iPhone
and the whole place,
Roy is like back when you
can get Congress to laugh.
Like everybody's laughing at
what a fucking idiot you are.
These are the people that
are asking the questions.